[Music]
we did a segment earlier where we did a
quick joke about Nicolas Cage and then I
remembered during the commercial break
you worked with Nic Cage really and I
find him fascinating III he's one of my
I got to interview him a few times and
he was just a fascinating guy to talk to
he's different than other ventric he's a
quite eccentric we did from God knowing
gosh maybe five or six years ago now he
was he's a real gentleman he's lovely
but a true eccentric gets we we did a
press conference at some point during
for the film and he before we went in he
turned to me and he said I'm gonna do
this whole thing without saying I or me
did he do that we sat there yeah a date
and he and for what reason
just three Zion amusement I'm not sure I
don't know it but it was fantastic I was
like how can you do this thing when one
has to make it like can you do that I
don't know I would just yeah I would say
if they asked if I was doing that I
would just say well Conan would not do
that
Conan would be otherwise you know just
to talk about yourself no no no it's a
sign you've made it I think you know
what
Conan disagrees
you must still have I mean pretty much
getting to meet everybody you've been so
successful do you occasionally have
those Hollywood moments where you
realize I've made it I have this is this
is great this is I'm having one of those
cool moments were on either with a huge
celebrity or something's happening and
now I know I've made it I but I did say
I remember when I saw Jack Nicholson
once very early when I had write there's
no there's no bigger star than him right
he's just such an icon and um we're at
basketball
of course cuz he's always there famous
and and we spotted him across the room
and then and we went to go to the
bathroom and we were waiting in line and
there was like one store four women and
one store four men anyway a woman had
gone into the men's and then so we're
waiting and Jack Nicholson came up and
it was like stood right there and we're
like and and he's like are you in line
yeah yeah but there's a woman who's gone
in to the men she's breaking the rules
you know so we're just waiting and he's
like maybe we should break the rules too
[Laughter]
so that night you robbed a liquor store
[Laughter]
you're just sure you're gonna be in a
remake of Annie yeah okay what part are
you playing
I play grace Farrell who is she's or
Daddy Warbucks is now called mr. stacks
is playing being played by Jamie Foxx
and I'm he's the CEO of his company so
yes that's cool now it's every it seems
to me if you're interested in acting as
a child is it am I wrong doesn't every
little girl want to play Annie
absolutely I supply it at school so it's
totally surreal to be part of it and I
would always be like I want to plan I
get to plan it because I have curly pegs
I had very curly but we have a photo of
you but when when you were a kid and yes
you have I mean it's not the the bright
red that it's supposed to be but you
would actually make a better
[Applause]
I wasn't sure how to take that but now
yes ladies and gentlemen it's wrong and
every I'm not only a mime an older man
[Laughter]
one tooth now do you sing and dance is
this a film this is a film this is it
film yes yeah I'm you know I can sing in
the shower I will say I'm getting
training so yep okay yep are you someone
who likes to sing in the shower yeah I'm
not gonna sing now though no no you
don't deceive no I sing like crazy in
the shower oh just you know what do you
got no I don't do i I do like old
traditional iris Oh
my wife is always certain thinking like
why is it suddenly the 1920 around still
exactly no no she left me but she drops
by burn and then to get her things yeah
she has to get her stuff my wife is
still with me
our marriage is behind us I donated joke
about a strange way for Conan to reveal
that